[Music]
foreign
here in this video we will discuss in
detail about the large infected form
that appeared in episode 5 of the loss
of us and how to take it down so let's
get to it the bloaters are a type of
infected that are seen first in the
video game and now in episode 5 of The
Last of Us series they are one of the
toughest and the most dangerous infected
in that Universe requiring a person to
employ a variety of tactics to defeat
them although the one that appeared in
Kansas City wasn't killed but managed to
overrun the human survivors and kill all
of them with the help of an army of
clickers and runners let's rewind a bit
and go over the backstory of how these
infected and a massive nine feet tall
bloater of Kansas City came to be well
what is known to us is that after the
outbreak and the entire world going to
[__] which means almost being destroyed
by the goddess of infection fedra a
militaristic post-apocalyptic tyranny
took control over most of the U.S
survivors in quarantine zones in Kansas
City the resistance managed to overthrow
Federer and take control it was later
revealed that Federer had driven most of
the infected into tunnels and sealed
them off thus over a long time the
runners transformed into the stronger
clickers and over time even the bloater
managed to evolve due to years of the
fungus growing in it well the one seen
here is the result of the late stage
fungal infection caused by the concepts
fungus which has taken over the host's
body and caused massive growths to
appear all over the body as a result
this individual this blower was very
large it was a hulking creature with a
bloated appearance covered in thick
fungal growths that makes it extremely
durable bloodos are typically
encountered later in the game and can be
found in areas where heavy fungal growth
is Optimum such as abandoned buildings
and underground tunnels in which the TV
series took to heart and properly
adapted as such the one in the show was
also released from an underground
channel that was sealed by fedra
they move slowly and make loud groaning
noises that can be heard from a distance
making them difficult to sneak up on in
combat bloaters are extremely dangerous
and can deal a lot of damage to
survivors with their attacks they can
throw Spore bombs and explode on impact
releasing a cloud of toxic spores that
can quickly overwhelm a person if they
are not careful gloras are also able to
charge and slam people with their
massive arms in episode 5 the blower was
leveled up in power and ferocity it was
able to tear a man's head clean off of
his shoulders with ease and appeared to
not be heard in any way by bullets or
Firearms overall Lotus are one of the
most challenging and intimidating
infected forms in The Last of Us only
coming in second to the Rat King killing
one a bloater requires careful strategy
and preparation to defeat a blower one
must use a combination of range attacks
such as Firearms or Throne explosives
and Close Quarters combat melee Attacks
An not recommended as they can be easily
overwhelmed by the bloated strength and
durability and also the blower has an
echolocation ability so it will know
when you are charging towards it one can
also use distractions such as balls or
brakes to lure the blower away from the
position you know making a sound to
distract it as a decoy and create an
opening for attack so it's pretty clear
as to why the bloat is seen in episode 5
wasn't taken down it had the element of
surprise and therefore there was no time
to plan out a way to kill it and the
army of clickers at the same time were
just too overwhelming for the survivors
bloaters do have several weaknesses that
one can exploit in combat they are not
invulnerable nor are they that hard to
kill given time and proper planning
their heavily mutated appearance makes
them very slow and cumbersome which can
also be used to a person's Advantage
they are also vulnerable to fire as the
fungus on their body is highly flammable
most of cocktails and other incendiary
weapons can be a very effective way to
kill a bloater due to their outgrowth in
the body bullet fire selum does anything
to it except turn up its temper to over
nine thousand also a headshot is really
hard to get due to the excessive fungal
growth on the size of the broken skull
acting like an armor
anyway they are thought to be the final
stage of the goddess of infection the
bloaters but there are a couple of
variations that would be encountered
well at least in the game the first is
the standard blower which is encountered
in the later stages the second one is a
blower infected which is encountered in
the game's multiplayer mode this blower
infected is smaller and less dangerous
than a standard one but still poses a
significant threat there's also another
alternate form which is found in humid
places where water is abundant and this
one is called the shambler anyway that's
about it that's all about the bloater
let's hope we see the Rat King in future
episodes this infected form is one to
die for
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit that like button for
support and subscribe but most of all
smash the Bell icon for regular updates
on new videos right here on this channel
till the next one take care fam